[Music]
move [ __ ] the way submitted by
Singapore love shake away all thank you
and we love Singapore 72 year old woman
is now on trial for punching a driver
who refused to make way for her
[ __ ] Ferrari a 17 year old
woman are are either yeah no she punched
someone in the face was gonna move oh I
think the Ferrari is a lot more Wow than
the punching yeah because my grandma
would punch people in the face she was
she said she's a gangster remember what
the Cheesecake Factory the [ __ ] pasta
came out she ate it she spit it out and
then I was always rush things way too
salty and oily and then the waiter came
and then excuse me you can take this
back but too salty for my grandma
oh can you tell me what's wrong with it
and then my grandma was like tell them
what was chef to eat this and see if he
could even stomach this I don't like
good thing you speak Chinese and they
didn't know what the hell she kept going
in front of the way that she's like oh
my god was a gay man that [ __ ] out yeah
so this lady her name is she she's 72
years old she's an architect from
Singapore oh yes apparently she was on
this one-way street and this man named
Raphael he's 39 years old so he had
moved his cards off to the side of the
road because he was waiting for a
parking spot so he says like he was
there for maybe about five to ten
minutes and in that time to be waiting
and in that time there were other cars
and even buses that had passed him so
there was plenty of room for this lady's
Ferrari to fit through the bus and a
fries not the same thing she knows that
but one is way more wider than this is
huge but Ferrari Geass is not personal
space if I had a fire someone was 20
feet away I probably gonna get the
[ __ ] working that's a wide range
always looking for eyes so she stopped
her car in the middle of the road
blocking the rest of the traffic so the
traffic started piling up she was
shouting at r-fl and honking tell him
move away man yeah and so that's when a
passerby noticed all this commotion and
that's when he posted his phone out ya
know he offered ya no no video sorry man
he offered to help direct traffic to
like help her get through because there
was plenty of space for her to get
through but she refused she was like
nope what if she has like a Alzheimer's
attack or something like something
forgets her shoes I hope she's not
driving yes a carriage mystical past huh
yeah so then she'd get that of her red
Ferrari walks up to a field car reaches
through the driver door and punches him
in the face causing his right eyebrow
start bleeding immediately man that hard
my hat rings huh told her like I'll
report this to police so then she just
said go ahead so she got into her car
Ferrari and ended up driving off we've
been so sad there was no look he drove
off you drove off before the cops got
there I wouldn't be able to tell a
grandma that just punched me I'm calling
the cops
yeah you probably wouldn't be able to
tell the car it's either I punched the
grandma or I let it go yeah there's only
two options you can do if a grandma
socks you it's you sit there like a
little [ __ ] and say sorry even if it's
her if it's her fault or you [ __ ]
grabbed her by her afro and you smack
her face and then you hope that no one
do you picture her in a tracksuit I
picture her to dress and look like a
grandma but she just came out of a
Ferrari I don't I don't see her as a
young lady
what if she's super buff like jack in
the [ __ ] City that does look like a
rich grandma that drives a Ferrari looks
like a bomb yeah but I picture like a
senior citizen with a little dress and
pearls curly hair that's great she has
those like sunglass work kind of fades
theatres with the [ __ ] thing that
connects like this well yours
reow girl yeah her lawyer she's lawyer
is saying that the punch was only a slap
okay it wasn't even that crazy and that
apparently she slapped him instinctively
after Rafael had uttered vulgarities to
her according to her so um well she
cannot she was a mom for so many years
that as soon as someone talks about it's
just a reflex the house out [ __ ] you're
not my kid I'm sorry yeah the witness
ended up stating that Rafael didn't say
any vulgarities to her that the only
thing he did say to her was don't blame
me if you're a lousy driver and then
that's what she punched oh that's a
vulgar statement I think that's begging
for a punch that's not even you're not
saying anything bad but you are
offensive yeah don't blame me that you
suck at life you know you're not really
saying a bad word but yeah you should
get smacked for that what if she was
like move over you [ __ ] [ __ ] you
[ __ ] [ __ ] I look at I mean to me
that's like a barking Chihuahua it's an
old lady right so if I if I saw that oh
yeah you know what I should have be here
cuz Raffy or whoever he shouldn't have
been there right well he was waiting for
a parking space yeah wait was there a
car like in front of them that was
moving I'm not exactly sure just the
only way that they described this team
is that it was a one-way street but it
was a really wide street cuz even though
the witness is saying like yeah there
were plenty of cars that were passing by
before her even buses right yeah so I'm
not sure where exactly she was it's just
fated that he was waiting for a parking
space and even she went by afterwards
and punching him and he didn't even move
you shouldn't even be getting out of the
car that lady crazy yeah the lady yeah
so then the witness also said he can't
remember which hand
she used to punch him but it was the
hand with lots of rings so then that's
what caused the cut on his eyebrow is it
possible that women's PMS just get worse
and worse so that's why when she was 72
it's like the worst PMS it makes sense
that's when you stop your period
completely mid-50s and then it's even
worse because the period stops right
your estrogen level is dropping her
testosterone takes over so it's the
worst PMS ever
it's not even PMS anymore it's man rage
so she has man rage that's why grandmas
they become the boss and the grandpas
they just relax it's true
yeah because apparently she tried
punching him a second time but he dodged
her oh yeah so they're saying like this
the child just began that's why it's
been reported because this actually
happened back in 2014
oh no I'd give her a pass she's a
grandma she's an architect she drives up
done so this is just one she was lovely
no so well first of all they're saying
that if she is convicted for this for
causing hurt that she will be jailed up
to two years and/or be fined
approximately 3,600 US dollars that's
too much we pay that those two years in
prison is kind of extreme for like a
little punch but it's Singapore like
that's like two years in prison at
$3,000 it seems like really but it was a
door and it would be it could be two
years or to say I totally pay for their
lifetime achievements though let me tell
you her life yeah what building is she
design well I'm not sure about the
building but okay so she's also facing
six other trials like other crimes
yeah none related so there were three
charges in this one incident where she
trusts best and harassed her neighbor
for her protruding tree onto her
neighbor's property so the neighbor
hired an arborist to cut down whatever
was on their property make sense and so
she goes over she tells the neighbor you
cut my tree my tree is my living thing I
hope your kids die she just apparently
she remembers oh so she's a [ __ ]
witch according to the recent book that
came out that's a best-seller in Germany
trees are a living thing and they just
killed her son no wonder she wears all
black washable which of the ether
apparently she removed the key from the
ignition of the arborist cherry picker
leaving him stranded up in the tree for
a whole hour
I like this lady he's [ __ ] crazy
despicable so then the neighbor in order
to stop her from getting away the
neighbors stood in front of her Porsche
so she had like Ferrari and a Porsche
Porsche it's both be Porsche okay
Porsche
she's very accomplished in my opinion
yeah so then he stood in front of her
Porsche to stop her right but that
didn't stop her she ended up revving her
engine in the car towards him so I don't
know if she actually made impact with
him or not but I just know that the
neighbor won and so she was ordered to
pay thousands of dollars in damages hmm
and then she's also facing two other
charges which I don't know the outcome
of this but the two other charges
was for for her stopping her car in the
middle of a road to tell another driver
to return to China Chinese right
this thing probably is probably Chinese
so her name is Sheikh ie spy Chinese
she's done Singapore's like Taiwan where
it's I guess its own theme but majority
is like Chinese people it's like Chinese
blood but it's she's probably telling
like mainland Chinese the airs part of
mainland China I always find out very
ironic because Chinese people telling
Chinese could they do that in Taiwan to
go back to China man [ __ ] you and I wait
how about you I was here I came here two
flights earlier Gold I am an ancestor of
Taiwan one generation ago gold back so
you're saying that if you're in this
guy's shoes let's say you didn't say
anything to her she just pops up next to
your your window and just punches you in
the face is a Singapore yeah all right
doing [ __ ] in Singapore Singapore I am
NOT even gonna disrupt anything because
if you speak Gump
if you speak Gump you'll go to jail if
I'm in Singapore just kick my ass
because I'm gonna do [ __ ] but if I'm
over here I'm a [ __ ] punch that grime
on the TT you're gonna punch her in the
titty she'll fill it I'm a [ __ ] grab
her [ __ ] denture pull it out or a
[ __ ] mouth and slap her in the face
with it and throw it on the ground
that's Wow just kidding I'm not gonna do
that she's a grandma
if she hits me it's like oh okay I'm
but loose skin and then [ __ ] tighten
not with it if she's like a MMA grandma
oh you've been watching some videos of
like some senior citizen karate masters
that can [ __ ] break [ __ ] with their
body age is no excuse man if she [ __ ]
me up and gives me like a heart punch
and I'm like oh I'll be like oh [ __ ] I'm
gonna run so fast not the response I was
expecting and I think if I was in that
situation I'd be so shocked like that
just really happened so what happens
when the second punch comes I think I
would get here cuz I'm just so like
shocked like that but the third punch of
go I keep punching just gonna keep on
low I have third one I'd be like okay
this [ __ ] yeah if it's a weak grandma a
[ __ ] rassa poorer head into your car and
then roll up the window yeah and then
drive off oh I'm she gets convicted
though [ __ ] that [ __ ] leave her in and
take her tomorrow she's just stressed
guys come on [ __ ] sad and if you
aspire to be her cuz you're like okay I
just understand thanks for watching just
kidding news guys don't forget to
comment down below we want to hear what
you say only if it's positive remember
that to watch more videos go up here
baby bear
[Music]